they allowed their prisons to be emptied
out into the United States of America
they allowed their mental institutions
to be emptied out into the United States
of America never happened Common Sense
would tell you that if you had common
sense you wouldn't be doing that
Mike would know that but you wouldn't be
doing this by the way Trump's pointing
to Mike pillow millions and millions of
people are coming and no country would
be able to withstand this no country
whether you're rich or poor and we're
not really rich we owe as of this
morning 31 trillion dollars right so I
don't know you call it rich I guess I
don't know maybe not this is really
helping me to mourn and grieve with the
diamonds family we spend a lot of money
on other countries and many of those
countries hate us so we give them money